hey everybody we got something totally
different going on today
oh my loud sorry about that whoa hold on
a second I am like really really loud
haven't been up in this setup for a
while let's see here testing one two one
two there we go that's much better we're
doing something totally non-political
today this is the David Pakman show
chess tournament rescheduled from last
December I guess right now I'm gonna let
everybody know I am The Champion this is
the 2019 trophy only one game was played
I defeated Pat and Pat is playing as you
can see here Pat Forde 94 that's
producer Pat he's in the game and this
starts at the top of the hour I think
this will be a good Brit by the way
whoever wins today gets a trip we will
have a trophy made and sent to the
winner today and I'm actually shocked I
was hoping for 50 players we already
have a hundred and two and we have
players ranked all rated all the way up
to what are the top rated players we
have players
well provisionally in the 2000s but
certainly in the 1900s and I've even
been defeated previously by some of
these players so right now I am I am
sort of like in the middle I guess I
don't know I I don't expect to do
particularly well but I think that this
will be good if you're just joining me
you can join that so you can watch my
games if you watch the stream but you
can play everybody who wants to complain
there's a link in the description on
YouTube and twitch you can just go to
david pakman.com slash chess and it'll
redirect you to the tournament link and
as you can see we have 10 minutes until
it until it starts I'm actually shocked
at number one the number of players I
was hoping for 50 I'm shocked that the
number of usernames mimicking me
like there's someone who's going by
David Pakman with two N's
in the chat in the in the turn That's
not me and of course I'm trying to ban
them
I can't because Li Ches doesn't allow
you to do that so I'm Pakman David
that's that's me and I think it shows
that I'm the host yeah you can see up
here the tournament is hosted by Pakman
David so I think this will be fun you
know with number one I'm trying to
provide people something to do who
people who are in the 20 states that
have actually been doing you know the
self isolation stuff number two it's a
community building thing number three
there's been so many of these
coronavirus briefings that I've been
that I've been doing live that it just
seems like this will be a good thing to
do once again you can find the
tournament at david pakman.com slash
chess that'll redirect you to the URL
that is also in the description on
twitch and youtube and then you can join
everything this is all free everything's
free at our expense then we will have a
trophy made as you can see oh this thing
is heavy
I am the 2019 champion david pakman
david pakman show chess champion this
was actually a birthday gift from from
the team for me technically correct
though but we will make one and we will
send it I am the I am an undisputed
champion right now as people are asking
we will make a trophy maybe I mean with
the number of people we have right now
we have a hundred and fifty-eight people
if a bunch of 160 if a bunch of these
people stay to the end maybe we'll even
do like first second and third place
trophies we'll get like a really big
trophy and then we could get like a
second place and a third place trophy
remember we're funding all of this so
anybody who wants to contribute in any
way to the trophy costs or anything else
grab a twitch subscription send a super
chat I'll read Super chats until the top
of the hour when when things get going
grab a membership at join pakman.com
many many ways to support all of the
different things like the stream if
you're watching on youtube or follow if
you're watching on Twitch many many free
things you can do we are up to a hundred
and sixty-five that you know I'm
actually pretty pleased with myself I
didn't think I could get even a hundred
of my viewers to participate in a chess
tournament
and I think this is this is great a
hundred and sixty-seven maybe we'll even
get like 200 players by the time it's
ready to go until the time we're ready
to go live if you're just watching you
are probably going to see me get
brutally crushed in a bunch of these
games looks like I'm still a little bit
loud turning that down there we go now
we've got police and stuff going crazy
it's wild out there so anyway you can
watch my games and you can also play you
can do both you can do neither I guess
you could also leave who knows but the
chess tournament is at david pakman.com
slash chess
I see people unable to find how to join
the link is in the description for the
twitch stream the YouTube stream I
tweeted it the david pakman show account
tweeted it and we've set up a redirect
at david pakman.com slash chess okay
that should be it should be findable let
me say thanks to Blake feely who grabbed
at which Prime subscription oatmeal
dragon is also a new twitch prime
subscriber and solid snake in my pant as
HuffPo boy has also grabbed a twitch
Prime subscription very very much
appreciated so I've gotten a million
questions from people about by the way a
lot of provisionally fifteen hundred
rated people these are people who just
made accounts to play which is fine so
people have been asking me okay so
people are sending me challenges now as
you can see I obviously am you know
we're about to play in a tournament
we're not going to do that right now
the system will start I think the way it
works is it'll initially start matching
people based on ratings provisional or
otherwise and then as you win or lose
every win is worth two points draw is
worth one point loss is worth zero you
will then you know be matched up against
people who are roughly your level so we
actually oh my goodness we have someone
rated 20 to 98 someone rated 2200 the
casual players like me are about to get
completely crushed interestingly out of
200
six I mean there's a lot of 1500s that
are provisional I'm like pretty far down
so this is this is gonna get incredibly
ugly incredibly ugly but I think it's
gonna be a good time at the end so well
I mean we have enough people we have two
hundred and thirteen people playing now
which is awesome we'll do trophies for
first second and third place we'll do
that I'll spring for that but you need
to get in touch with me it's got to be
through leech s cuz it'll be public who
won
someone could email me and say hey I'm
you know bouche Magoo Schiff bouche
Magoo Schwinns and I wouldn't know if
you are or aren't so first second and
third place at the end of this you've
got to contact me through the Lea chess
system and as you can see here I'm
pakman David in 'only chess if you're
just joining us we are four minutes from
the start of the David Pakman show
twenty twenty coronavirus quarantine
chess tournament anybody can play it's
all free you can sign up on li chess org
and then you can go to david pakman.com
slash chess it'll redirect you here
there's like a joint tournament button I
guess it would be where the withdraw
button is now if you're not in the
tournament yet oh boy
so guy I obviously I'm not accepting
challenges right now because we are
about to start a tournament and I'll be
playing in the tournament people very
very excited apparently to challenge me
I see a lot of user names like Pakman is
done for
Pacman's going down and stuff like that
I'm gonna now silence my phone
everything going off at the same time
people oh I see those are notifications
on my phone of people challenging me
delete delete delete we're getting off
of all that stuff
very good three minutes until the starts
geez that thing's getting very very much
out of control we have 236 players now
ready to go
can we get to 250 I was thinking it
would be like 50 maybe a hundred imagine
if we could get to 250 250 players in
this thing it would be beautiful if
you're just here to watch that's fine
a lot of you are gonna see me get beat
badly in a lot of these games and then
in between games I will come back here
to the leaderboard to see to see who's
doing what and again we have one two
three four people rated 2,000 or above
ten and ten people at 1900 of above or
above seventeen at 1800 of above so I'm
gonna get crushed but it's gonna be a
fun time I think that that's that's the
important thing for everybody we are
just three players from 250 I think we
call this a success if we get to 250
players right I mean we've never done
this before
and some people are saying they're not
playing because the rating is 600 who
cares just just play you'll get the the
system uses data and math to match
people up against people roughly of
their skill level so I say no matter
what your skill level is play we did it
253 somehow I'm more proud of getting
254 people to play in my chess
tournament then when we get like 12,000
people on a livestream like we did
earlier this week something about this
is just much more much more exciting 258
it's climbing its this is getting crazy
now the one thing I'm worried about is
whether I have my windows scaled
correctly so that ok now I'm not doing
not doing challenges right now hopefully
the chessboard will display correctly if
not I'm gonna have to maybe adjust a
little bit this could also be hugely
embarrassing because I could end up
getting brutally brutally crushed and it
could just be like my street cred to the
extent that I have any I don't I just
don't know you know it could really
damage the show in a lot of ways let's
see here ok we are under a minute away
if anybody is wondering I see a lot of
people still asking how to play david
pakman.com slash chess david pakman.com
slash chess
you'll get redirected
no word whether puh puh puh puh [ __ ]
will be browning out of this debate I
don't know if you guys saw this crazy
hilarious david pakman twitch boomer
compilation that was made I tweeted it
earlier if you don't understand that
reference definitely definitely check
out all right we could conceivably get
to 300 players and you can you can join
by the way after the tournament starts
we are 15 seconds away let's get to 300
players 9 8 7 oh my god 5 4 3 2 1 zero
here we go oh and we're off alright here
we go everybody playing their games I
did no buzzer King by the way under the
auspices that we want higher quality
chess oh you can't even see my bottom
row I'm gonna have to fix that in a
second hold on geez I'll have to fix
that between games I think bear with me
guys here it is okay so I'm gonna go
like this I'm just fixing this so
everybody can see what's going on Wow
total fail can you imagine there we go
alright now we got it very good okay
we're continuing to play here now my
phone's going off everything is
happening at once this is this is truly
unbelievable playing against just Jason
okay let's see oh whoops no I don't want
to do that
we want to do here so I'm gonna play
this way maybe look to castle just Jason
giving up the night early all right
we'll be castling now thinking about
moving over here then maybe getting
uh-hmm
very good
now I'm thinking here just to get things
moving out of the way and then maybe
here hmm okay so here then probably I
guess here would be the move but then
what that's the question let's do it
and I'm thinking maybe here mmm that's
interesting guess I have to move back
hmm this first game not going that well
I think maybe I just take it and then
push the Queen back really has to take
with the Queen no other choice unless
Wow
wow that's that's surprising all right I
guess now I move back
if I move here could i potentially trap
the Queen if now because this space is
still safe for the Queen let's see here
here here here yeah let's let's try to
actually that may have been a terrible
move for the Queen right I guess here or
here hmm interesting see what Jason does
Jason thinking curious how producer
Pat's doing right now okay well you just
gave up the Queen that doesn't really
make sense okay I guess let's move out
here
free Pandu I just take it I guess here
hmmm I think we go here then I move out
of the way maybe here interesting I'm
considering any number of moves right
now hmm Jason's running a little bit low
on time I will say I'm actually unsure
okay yeah just do this for now maybe
here what what on earth just happened oh
okay
interesting I think that there's
probably a very obvious good move here
which I'm missing when you go here and
then take here if takes with the bishop
Jason getting very low on time
okay hold on a second hmm I'm actually
unsure I just want to make sure nothing
weird happens in the back here if I move
out of the way
I might just do this Jason very low on
time very very low on time dangerously
low okay
and Jason resigned all right let's go
let's go back to tournament see what
we've got so far some people already
with 4 points and on a streak not
surprisingly Eric Rosen's playing oh hey
Eric
that's I think Eric may I don't know how
Eric ended up in this tournament but
Eric is a likely candidate to do very
very well here I've never done this
before as people can probably tell all
right here we go now we've got a game
we've got a serious game here okay so
I've played this before a number of
times I think I'm going here
okay now this is an interesting I've had
this a line before we're gonna just try
something in fact we're gonna try
something Eric Rosen himself taught me
let's see what happens okay let's see I
believe this is an attempted fried liver
attack okay then I think in this line I
play over here I'm trying to remember
this one the problem is when it goes in
a different direction I really don't
remember what I'm supposed to do here
you know here I take the bishop but then
what think I take here then often this
defending here Oh
didn't do it so I think I just take the
knight right I mean is there any reason
not to people challenging me as if I'm
going to interrupt the tournament
I think I just take the night yeah I've
never actually had that before in this
situation and then
yeah that's a problem now this is the
problem here
down here hmm that's a very problematic
maybe that's why I shouldn't have taken
the night is this lost I guess no I
could I could save the root because if
this let me think this through here here
and then here that doesn't make any
sense
if I go here first this pawn is
undefended and then maybe here but then
this is undefended huh I mean I guess I
just have to save the rook right I don't
I don't know that I really have another
choice right now
maybe now here I just don't know what to
do about that
I guess just back then this is free yeah
I mean I think that I don't think I even
have any other real moves and also want
to give up castling rights so if this
then this what do i do that's the
problem I don't know that it's to my
advantage I think maybe here actually
makes more sense and then maybe now
problem is that so then okay we trade
pawns oh no no no that doesn't work
because then here and then we're in
major major trouble maybe here first
this is actually getting ugly hmm
right okay maybe think I've got to get
this Bishop going this is already very
very ugly maybe we're going back hmm oh
my god what am i doing I just lost my
queen do I even play it out or do I just
resign I don't even know that it makes
sense yep you know what I'm gonna take
the loss and get back to the tournament
let's see who's in first blank page
doing very very well
interesting could it be that Eric is
Reilly in 28th he must be just very much
slow playing everything that's going on
let's see what we've got here somehow
I'm losing and getting put up against
even better players which does not seem
like it's to my advantage
hmm they go right for the Queen force a
defensive move
I think I'm better off taking Queen I
come at a castle this way hmm actually
you know I kind of like maybe I like
this better this might be to my
advantage in some way in the future
hmm I think I might want to try to
maneuver this night around if possible
so here and here and then what is it to
my advantage to trade there or do I
trade later hmm I think I'm actually
gonna play this way and see what white
does right and then I think I want to
get my rook here and then maybe double
up the rooks is it it's it's a semblance
of an idea although I don't know how
much it'll help me I mean I guess I
double up although I I just don't know
that it's gonna be that useful I think
I'm not interested there hmm
now where do we go yet that Tyler sends
a super chat and says he Tyler
suggesting that I checkmate okay well I
mean that's that that's an idea so let's
see what's that what is the idea there
hmm I think I might keep moving here and
then maybe look at this and this I just
it's sort of this is where I sort of
lack imagination so this and this and
then I've got to be careful here
maybe I just leave the leave leave the
tension there so to speak and maybe make
an attempt here I would trade these
pawns maybe and then this way right so
that was not a good idea
I mean I guess I have to defend is there
any other possibility I think maybe I
need to start getting my King to a
different square I don't know now it's
getting ugly I mean do I have to then is
this it you can't really move this pawn
right because then well I guess I have
to watch for this rook moving hmm I
consider this game a win in that Juno's
rated 1600 and it's I haven't
embarrassed myself yet yet can I
maneuver the night somewhere useful
maybe let's try it so if I go here I
don't know that it's actually to my
advantage but then here here check would
that do anything not really I think I go
right for the rook first let's see what
happens
I think now I push the pond because now
I do have three pieces here ah there we
go
that was expected
maybe I push again but now what now I'm
potentially in trouble
yikes maybe I just take this pawn I
think I'm kind of stuck guys I don't
think this is good I can't take here
I've got to move this rope but where -
maybe here and running low on time as
well let's go here and then here
this is getting very very ugly oh boy
maybe here getting very low on time now
this ponds gone ponds dead yep I guess I
attacked the rook and just see what I
can get out of it
nothing okay oh boy this is bad
go back at the rook and back at the rook
other rook and rook again and check free
pond but now I'm dead this is gonna be
oh wait maybe not hold on a second
man but now what
hmm not good not good
maybe I just defend here oh no that the
Knights defended by the pawn what am i
doing
I had another check there check here and
oh boy that's not good I think I'm
taking here then I'm going back to the
check this is getting tight guys that
may be it
oh I had that rock oh boy what am i
doing that was the complete wrong move I
can't believe I just did that I think I
just had a beautiful move and did I just
miss a free rook there I think I did I
think I just missed a free rook I cannot
believe that
oh man I don't think I can do anything
else here that was that that was a free
rook as well it's all going wrong here
yep good game I'm gonna have to go back
and analyze that one Wow let I think I
missed a free rook a few moves back
there let me see here
I think that was a mistake my opponent
made right wait a second where was it
now it was before this what am i doing I
I had a free rook and what did I do
I moved the King out of the that isn't
that is horrible that is horrible it was
a mental mistake all right let's get
back to the tournament who's in first
right now Erick and Contra right up
front that I actually had a shot at that
game I mean listen that's a much better
player than me right so I'm just I'm
telling myself that that was not that
was not I would last it way longer than
I would have expected in that one but
that I had a free rook there
unbelievable and that timer was very
very much getting on my nerves
incredible incredible people are just
joining oh I should mention if people
are just joining Ricardo Garcia is new
member number four during the stream
want to thank Ricardo as I wait for my
next game whoa
and Julian Rhodes also grabbed a
membership on my website at join
pakman.com I don't know how but we have
like 1600 people watching this right now
which is crazy I never would have
imagined that just some random chess
tournament that I do would have 1600
people watching all right going to the
pawns eonni here unusual play from Caleb
II not familiar with this particular
sequence okay that's a free queen that's
weird
unusual start to this one I'm not gonna
lie
all right let's get the Queen back
somewhere a little more reasonable man I
really had a shot at that last one guys
I had that that one that one stings guy
gave me a rook and I just moved my king
away can you imagine
amazing amazing I'm gonna have to go
look at look at that one once more I
think after that's a free Bishop the
cysts that is definitely an unusual game
caleb he's given away a lot of his
pieces I think that that's that's maybe
not the ideal thing to be doing
13:42 certainly seems like a provisional
rating for now okay all right back to
the tournament that was the I needed the
win I needed the recovery there because
that that last loss was just brutal
let's see who's in first okay Eric is in
first how anybody know if Eric's
streaming as well unsure interesting all
right here we go again also how many
people are playing right now in the
tournament in total I don't know what
our total number of players is
so the way I was actually taught this
Eric taught me this is if takes here I
push the pond but I tend to forget how
to play that yeah and I often have
better results
taking back here and then pushing again
and I know that this pond is free but it
tends to work out later for me but it
may it may not in this particular case
thanks down Latino for the super chat
super chat also thanks to Gustav von
Kats for the twitch prime sub casual Jam
as well as dream evolution and of course
Solid Snake in my pant signed up before
yeah so usually here then I'll play here
then the night gets out of the way
typically anyways as I've seen it played
in most cases now I'm trying to remember
sometimes that works see
hmm Hara Ranga thinking someone named Q
or xqc is playing here I don't know who
that is I don't know if I should know
who that is
okay so trying to remember the right
move here I've had this position a bunch
of times X Q C is a big time twitch
streamer Oh interesting and are they are
they playing here
I think I may start trying to load up
over here momentarily now let's just see
what if I sacrifice here here here or
alternatively here here here I don't
know that I really get anything out of
it now hold on a second yeah I don't
think that that'll work
hmm
it's not going great so far got to get
my other night involved and I'd really
like to castle okay
that's actually problematic in a few
different ways if I go here here here
here then I'm screwed so I definitely
don't want to do that if I block here I
think I might have to give up castling
rights I think I may have to because
although I'm gonna have to go back and
analyze that move but I think all the
other moves get me into more trouble
hmm that may or may not have been the
right one
what is it so xqc is currently playing
in this and streaming is that true I
don't even know what's going on XQ see
[Music]
okay I think I'm gonna take here and
then if here then I it's actually I just
take the night and then take the pawn I
think now also this is under attack I
think now I take here the only thing I'm
worried about is once here the King
can't take maybe I take now either way
this is happening here
hmm Hara Ranga is also getting a little
low on time that's the other issue nine
seconds I think I just take here this is
also happening all right that one's over
let me go back to the analysis board so
okay here what was the move oh okay so I
didn't I didn't make the right move this
was the right move then would have taken
then I could take okay all right so the
threat was not what would I believed it
to be that's good all right let's go
back to the tournament see who's in
first Eric is now on fire very very much
on fire and we've got a bunch of people
here three eight Wow 388 people in might
in my little tournament we I was hoping
for fifty let me say thanks to matthew
raza telly matthew just grabbed a
subscription on my website join
pakman.com matthew thank you I really
very much appreciate your support also
thanks to Kyle acha Kyle go Kyle
aka Kyle very much appreciate that
twitch subscription all right here we go
by the way anybody you you can join now
people who are worried like I see the
message from James Dean saying that you
know sorry he you can join at any time
the tournament we've still got a while
left in this tournament
you can join david pakman.com slash
chess we'll bring you right to it maybe
we could hit 400 players usually in this
situation I play this way we'll see yeah
so far I'm okay I think
mmm and usually go here and then usually
I lose instantly but then that's always
a possibility yeah and then usually my
move has been to take in this situation
and then to bring the night out
yeah david pakman.com slash chess you
can play so here here is that good or
instead I wait and then potential you
can bring the Queen out I think I'm
gonna leave that and actually maybe it's
an opportunity to get my bishop out and
if takes I just take with the bishop I
think now I take because now the bishop
can't really take
I'm hearing rumors we are at at 400
players that's that's amazing if true
okay let's see I think I'm in a castle
although I need to start figuring out a
way to open some of this up okay I'd
love to get the Queen activated but
where exactly
hmm yeah these positions I'm never
really sure where to go maybe I'll start
getting some pawns moving now I wonder
if there might be something here not
clear that there is not clear that there
is at all because I'll just wait and see
what black does thanks to cynic for the
cheer appreciate that Oh what was okay
there we go oh that certainly doesn't
help the case for what I was thinking of
doing I'm gonna just move I need to get
the Queen somewhere else and I'm just
not sure where maybe here want to avoid
any kind of this fork here is
potentially problematic I think I'm just
going to go here okay
people are saying I should change the
stream info on Twitch to chess I will do
that chess and done guys please stop
sending me challenges because it
triggers that noise every time which is
incredibly annoying and I'm not going to
be accepting any challenges right now
okay let's see here I mean I guess I
have no choice but to go here
and I guess I'm guess I'm back this way
really having to retreat here now this
point is of course undefended for now I
said I think there might be some
possibility here not exactly sure which
way to go I think maybe this way oh my
god I'm an idiot what on earth am i
doing wow that that was absolutely
idiotic okay
let's see wow that was that was like
weaponized bad chest jeez
let's see me I'll force him to move
something out of the way that was just a
disastrous disastrous move I think I
just lost the game on that move oh it's
now my Queens under attack think I'm
gonna move do I move the Queen actually
I think I just what do I do here
I can move here yeah that was that was a
disastrous move disastrous disastrous
move that was just a mental mistake I
mean as are as are they all on chess now
this is a real problem
oh okay miss that that's actually a
really good thing so I'm gonna take I
think I have to do I just take because
then this is a real problem because this
rook will end up being trapped do I just
take oh but then either way it's a
problem I think I'm taking the rook
first and then that I I it's a real
problem but I think that was the right
move I'll have to analyze that after Wow
and missed it incredible
thanks donkey show for gifting that sub
donkey show has gifted 82 subscriptions
on Twitch that's crazy okay so now I
believe I take here and I think I take
here hunt some making a couple mistakes
I think I think that some of these were
were mental mistakes I was really in
rough shape for a while at this point I
wouldn't even be against just trying to
trade here like let's see this is on
this uh do I want to do that I think I'm
going to let's just try to trade these
rooks and see where I get because then
this is a problem right here potentially
I'm thinking ahead
okay I don't think that was the right
move this is a risk right here does
Hudson protect against that does hunt
some run out of time or do I get
checkmated oh boy
gave away the Queen everything going
wrong all of a sudden yeah that always
Beth so let me go back to that analysis
board because at the beginning let's see
where was it that I was Oh aunt
arresting Lee so somebody told me I gave
away this white bishop too quickly but
it was the right move according to the
engine at the time I mean listen I I
know there's people in this tournament
probably better than the engine I'm now
I'm not one of those people should have
castled there where was the move that I
was confused about whether it was the
right one oh it was there it is right
this is where I gave away so here I
should not have taken because I just
give away the rook and that was really
bad went from plus 1 point 4 to minus
five point three boy brutal brutal all
right let's get back to it
eric has still not lost a game HB sin
hasn't lost a game rw2 lost the first
game but then has won everything ever
since let me say thanks to trevor bush
trevor bushes new member number 7 isn't
Trevor isn't Trevor Bush a NASCAR driver
or am i I don't know anything about
NASCAR new member number 7 is Trevor
Bush thanks to cynic and donkey show and
Charlie Richardson and all these great
people for subscribing and you know
doing all sorts of cool stuff alright
we're gonna keep going here this is not
an opening I'm familiar with in terms of
playing against so I'm just gonna have
to try to prevent it from being
weaponized Oh Kyle Busch Kyle
she's not Trevor Bush that's right okay
I think here and prevent that but then
of course this will just kick me away
didn't do it now that's a problem
potentially depending on what the
defense is cuz otherwise we've got this
okay yeah that's what I figured let's
see I think castling
I think I want to go in this direction
here and then maybe this if the pawn is
used to take otherwise I might just keep
pushing because we've got all this
happening hmm interesting do I do I
counter-attack or do I move the knight
here
I think I move the knight yeah I'm never
sure in those situations again if here
oh that's not good that's not that's not
great for me that is not great oh I know
this is not I think I know no that's not
good if this that's not good so we don't
want to do that I think maybe here I'm
planning it playing against fish a far
better player than I am right and then I
take back now I wonder if I could get in
position to at least threaten mate in
one so if I go here well that's not
mating one because of this square right
that's not so let's think that through I
go here if takes I just take back if not
though let's just try it and see if
it'll throw fish off because if here
here here okay protected against it now
this is available but then I lose my
queen so we don't want that definitely
don't want that
if I go here here here that doesn't
really work maybe I'm expecting this to
come pretty soon and I don't want to get
involved in that ugliness I think I'm
just gonna back off now the only problem
is this this this that pawn is
essentially a free pawn if fish is able
to track that down exactly as I wonder
if this person's watching me talk I hope
there's enough of a delay where that's
not the case um let me see here here
here here I think I can do that I think
this is okay I am down to pawns now
though and backed off okay I think I got
to get a rook going maybe do I go to the
open file do I try to get it aligned
with the Queen I think I'm gonna go to
the open file if you're just joining us
by the way this is the david pakman show
coronavirus okay I think I've got a
double up now
oh let's see this is defended but this
is double attacked I only have one
defender I could play here or move the
rook I think I might just open the rook
for now this is the david pakman show
coronavirus Quarantine chess tournament
anybody can play there's only 25 minutes
left in the tournament david pakman.com
slash chess and we had at last count
about 400 people playing I'm currently
in 71st position ok so now now we've got
a problem here and then here we only
have one so I think what I have to do I
think I have to add another defender
here right I think everything's coming
down to c6
do I want to push this pawn forward I'm
not sure okay so now I think I'm gonna
move here maybe we can maneuver all the
way around and directly go at the Queen
to some degree mmm thinking ahead well
let's let's go after the Queen and just
see what happens
Queen moves out of the way think I might
push forward here this is a very unclear
position for me now probably this Oh
didn't do it okay
that's okay pushing forward again I
think I might start getting my King in
oh no that's not good this is not good
actually I lost on time Wow
let's see what I should have done there
first of all how far do so I was
actually I thought that I was still in
this thing I was not it was not close at
all I was down 4.5 so I should have
played forward then taken hmm yeah I was
sometimes I feel like I'm not actually
down that much and I and I really am let
me say thanks to Deanna McGowan Deanna
McGowan has signed up at joined
pakman.com and his new member number 8
I'm gonna go back to the tournament in
first place right now is Eric Rosen
still followed by HB son
Pepe laugher Reno that's COO rfw is up
there alright here we go again this time
you know I keep losing and yet I keep
playing against better and better ranked
players that just doesn't seem fair
thanks to c-note for subscribing with
the message destiny got destroyed in
this debate okay so this is this throws
off my opening plan but I don't actually
remember what I'm supposed to play yeah
I'm not sure
I'll just play pons eonni as if it made
sense against these these retorts by
black even though I'm not sure that they
do keep pushing forward I get the night
into the action and here
I don't love this Bishop here that could
cause a problem for me do I gain
anything by throwing in a check here if
defends with the bishop or the queen
can't really take either unless I want
to trade Queens I don't know that that
really makes sense
maybe we can get the Queen to move out
of the way although probably would
defend this way no an idea I'm just
gonna try something see if I can okay
yeah didn't didn't work all right let's
do check now let's see what happens here
okay
now I'll see if I can get both my rook
and Queen lined up together not that it
really matters anymore but still a
possibility here right and that goes
away now we're to go hmm feeling a
little bit stuck not sure maybe just
start moving some of my pawns forward
right I think I might block this way not
usually the way I would play such a
position
I think I have to take now I wonder
about potentially this okay
well now now I no longer wonder about it
okay maybe we try to get the night to go
somewhere else okay
let's try this let's try it just to see
what happens
oh we're am i doing I'm in check right
okay so I guess I have no choice but to
move out of the way let's put this here
has to come here bishop hmm this one got
interesting all of a sudden I'm noticing
that that Lord overlay plays extremely
well where it's obvious that I'd have no
shot and then makes very weird mistakes
it's kind of strange okay so maybe now I
go right after the Queen actually I
might double up here oh no no I've got
to defend this night this night is
undefended if I go here here lose the
night so I can't do that I think I've
got to go here
yep anticipating that
hmm and where is the ripe spot maybe
here then probably here here maybe bring
this rook around yep so then I think I
attack the Queen this way this is a
fight as far as I can tell maybe I'm way
down right now I genuinely don't know
this is kind of ugly for me because of
these pawns it makes it hard to get
aligned properly
is there a sacrifice here that could
work
here here don't think there is don't
think there is I think maybe this kind
of has to back off Oh actually I see a
move I see a move that could be
problematic for black right here let's
see what black does yep I think that
this wins the Queen because even if
takes then I've got the Queen here yep
and that's checkmate wow wow what a turn
of events all right what was the move I
wanted to analyze there what was the
point at which but there was a point
here where I was thinking of Queen c2
and I never got to it and I'm curious it
was before the Queen moved out there it
was at this point I was considering
Queen c2 ok I guess I had something else
been done would that have been the right
move no it wouldn't have even at that
point it would not have been the right
move interesting interesting alright
before I get back let me make sure I'm
caught up on thanking everybody
Brandon Roach Brandon Roach is has just
signed up on my website and his new
member number nine today and let's see
who I think here yeah I think this is
okay
because here here and then we've got
this going on let's see what happens
against bread napkin very hard to know
who's good and who isn't because there's
clearly a lot of people who just signed
up today to play which is fine it's
great but makes it difficult to know you
know what's going on I think I'm taking
and then that's gonna open this up
Bigley sometimes I do well with these
with these situations I would have to
deal with this issue first before I can
move the Queen out anywhere else I think
there's really only one move here I
don't know what else
bread napkin is considering and you
basically have to take or you just go
down a full-piece yeah okay let's now
let's castle now of course no check here
because of this I would immediately lose
that mmm take take I know you've got two
pieces there I think this is okay
okay now actually that solves that
solves a problem for me
to be perfectly frank so I think I'm
good I'm still gonna try to get lined up
here at some point but we would have to
do something about these pieces because
these two squares are not accessible
right now okay I think I'm going back
down here
hmm I like how people are joining and
they had no idea that we've been
planning this tournament for a while and
they're like what's going data is just
randomly playing chess no weave this is
a tournament we've been planning for a
while it got postponed because of
impeachment and now we're you know it's
happening out so that's interesting now
this Square actually is accessible now
as a check because this is blocked but
it's very risky because I could there
could be a discovered attack there that
could get extremely ugly
let me just immediately go after this
Bishop since it's currently undefended
and see if we can get it away and then
maybe we could do a check here that
would move the King into the corner I
could then go here if I could defend the
square because otherwise the Queen takes
it actually that doesn't that doesn't
really help
okay now the Queen's under attack so if
I go here that's check has to move what
do I gain with that the other idea would
be here and then we're lining up this
way in case of the eventual move that
way you know I kind of like this idea
and I'm also defending this bishop I
think I'm going for that how can I get
maybe this rook working on this file
think maybe moving over bread napkins
also getting a little tight on time
which is interesting okay
so do I take the bishop I don't know
that I gain much by that maybe I just
play I think I go this way and now
that's dangerous though let's try it I'm
getting I'm not sure actually there's a
couple things I could have done here
okay yeah and so that's that was not a
good idea let's see what we got now
let's go here I think this is probably
my best move this is open that's the
only problem
but then this now hold on let me think
if I take the night first then could
come here move this way let's see how
about discovered check first now maybe I
take the free pawn although this pawn is
undefended it's a problem you know what
I think I'm taking here this could
really go any any way if it takes here
now I've got that going on I think I
have to hold on this is complex for me
if I take here just takes I can't do
that
maybe here to defend this pawn this is
ugly this is this is a mess Oh God
I think this is my only move and it's
checkmate
missed it missed it all right let's go
back a few moves and see what I should
have done so here is where in my mind it
started getting a little dicey I did
play the best move there
I should have see I decided not to do
the check because in my mind check and
then here so that's interesting so I had
the idea after this move to in advance
align my queen with where the King might
have to go if I get a check in of course
that didn't happen and what I should
have played was put the king in check
get it onto that square
and then actually pin the rook the
knight rather but I didn't do it I
didn't do it
very very interesting okay let me say
thank you to I don't have anyone else to
think that's depressing okay thanks to
Tyler and the residents for the super
chat Jeff Rogers got a youtube
membership Andrew Dwyer asked me what
Boston restaurant I miss the most
there's so many so many okay let's go
back to the tournament and see what's
going on Eric Rosen has lost one game
drawn one game and otherwise is
undefeated HB Sen is completely
undefeated but has played fewer games
than Eric so we have a we have a fight
at the top between Eric Rosen and HB Sen
and we have almost 500 people playing if
you want to get a few games in you can
join at david pakman.com slash chess
that will redirect you to the to the
tournament all right here I always play
this Oh interesting now I know that
there's a trap if I take this pawn I
think I'm gonna go here then check I've
played this way a couple of times and it
worked out okay I do need to come up
with something better for that because
that is a known opening
let's go this way yeah that's it that's
an open if people are asking how to play
it's david pakman.com slash chess that
will redirect you right to the
tournament everything this is all free
everything's free
of course if people want to you know
grab a membership at join pakman.com
we've got a goal here of 25 we're yeah
ok that's always much appreciated or you
know you send some bits grab a twitch
prime's whatever you want all right
let's put a check on the King likely
with the with the bishop there now
let's I kind of have a problem here
because I didn't develop some pieces and
that is a that's a real problem I think
now I'm gonna take with the Queen and
then we I've just got to get stuff
opened up here mister free pawn there
let's see what happens here this is this
that you know they got to do something
about this there it is okay
you be careful about a discovered attack
on the Queen here and there it is okay
oh my god I'm an idiot
uh what is my move here oh I'm sorry
yeah obviously this yeah that was an
idiotic move what on earth am i doing I
was too attracted by the Mayton one
possibility which which was not actually
made in one but that was that was maybe
my worst move other than giving away
that free Brook earlier disastrous move
disastrous move so I'm gonna have to get
out of the way here and then you know
maybe some kind of an attack on the rook
I've got to figure out what's the right
way to attack this rook no wait a second
now I think the rook has to come back
obviously this is a move also okay
so let's see here is there any way to
salvage this I think I've got to get out
of the way here
what can we do now I think how do I get
out of this mess is there any way out of
this mess is the question and I'm not
sure now this is a real real tough
situation let me think this through is
there any way potentially to get out of
this how could I attack this rook with
something other than my rook this
doesn't work
get over here that doesn't work either
maybe I could get out of a situation
where this bishop can't move maybe
that's a start well alright now I can't
do that I'm an idiot okay there's got to
be something here there's got to be
something here no maybe I just attack
this rook and hope I don't get made it
immediately but that is that yeah okay
very good all right but so now we're now
we're now we're not not playing well at
all
okay we are down to the last minute of
the tournament it's conceivable that I
am gonna get one more game in if we get
that was a painful loss guys that would
that was okay that was a really painful
loss that was a brutal one that was a
brutal one people can stop challenging
me I'm not playing any I'm just playing
in the tournament that's it it's funny
people constantly challenging me okay I
didn't do I mean listen I I got I got
some wins here I got one two three four
five wins that's not terrible
considering I I don't know at all what
I'm doing we do have at the top of the
tournament Eric Rosen now leading by
three points I'm a tournament pairings
are closed I'm out
all right so someone is going to get the
trophy we are doing first second and
third place trophies let's see if we can
watch whatever game eric is in oh it
doesn't look like he's in a game okay is
anyone even still playing that's ko is
in a game let's see if we can watch this
game this is one of the foremost games
going on in the tournament right now
Junior Mints versus that's Koo
a lot of weaponized nasty nasty moves
what's nastier some of the moves in this
tournament or some of the questions
Trump gets asked during those press
conferences
this game going nowhere fast my friends
thanks to Andy mint for subscribing
eight-months thank you very much
appreciate that well we could have a
situation here nasty nasty situation
this game may determine second versus
third place it's conceivable
interesting this is the perfect
situation where I would have no idea
what to play like I just have no idea I
know that I don't love these double
pawns like here I'd start thinking about
you know do I push this pawn maybe I
just have no sense in these particular
types of situations what to do we will
soon be announcing the winners first
second and third place of the David
Pakman show corona corona virus
quarantine chess tournament getting
dangerously close to being ready to do
that
Bishop d6 mmm
interesting thanks to Jared cam barrows
who says via super chat thanks for
getting our minds off kovat 19 yeah that
was the point of doing this today it's
just been so much so much coronavirus
stuff and it's you know we are living in
a bad in a dystopian science fiction
novel at this point we figured we would
do the tournament today
Daniel Rivera says I made it to the top
ten thank you David
I figured you would Daniel I figured you
would be one of the top contenders given
your very very strong and powerful
rating extreme instinct also sent a
ten-dollar super chat which is always
very much appreciated what's the move
here right and then this may be
go right at the Queen No
Oh
nasty move can the Queen get trapped
here interesting just so people know I'm
not in this game this is these are just
this is one of the last games going on
before the tournament ends quite a game
quite a game
that's a move missed king/queen fork
with night two age six it's a free night
but is there a more powerful move here
oh my god guys I'm not playing anymore
games please no more challenges no more
challenges that's cool really having to
think about this very interesting
situation see I'm right okay and then do
you take the night is the question
Junior Mints now thinking crucial moment
do you now go for the night or do you
attack the night with the pawn do you
take here here okay takes the night
ten seconds what a game what a game
going after the Queen
has to take now I'm not playing this
game now people are messaging me moves
this is not my game guys I'm not in this
game this is Junior Mints versus that's
cool and after this the tournament will
be over we'll announce winners and timed
out that is it ladies and gentlemen all
right let's go back to this whoa all
right congrats to Eric Rosen with 15
games played one 85% of them second
place HB Sin 1 92% of 12 games and then
that's qu ending in third place won
every single game but didn't play that
many games and that does it I have my
final standing is one hundred and thirty
fourth out of four hundred and ninety
seven let's see who had the worst day
did anybody lose like so some people
lost four games did anybody do worse
than that gorgeous angel lost six games
here's okay here's the thing whoever did
the worst gets a free item from my store
okay so clearly the worst would be zero
points but what we'll say is the worst
is whoever lost the most games in
getting to zero points so gorgeous angel
lost six games that's the worst so far
Tyrael if tied that by losing six games
that anybody lose more than six games
some people played one game and bailed
dr. no lost one two three four five six
seven oh my goodness dr. no lost eight
games I think that's the worst person we
did the worst so far anybody else who
was all zeros well no we have points
okay the worst the worst performance
today was dr. no who lost eight games in
a row
dr. no if you want a free item from my
online store t-shirt coffee mug data
mail t-shirt whatever get in touch the
three winners we are doing trophies
Esav lee large trophies get in touch and
get me your address will get you the
trophy these these are actual chess game
trophies and and really poor guy
doctor no I feel bad about that and so
in the end I mean listen out of 497 I
was in the top quartile roughly I don't
think that that's terrible
one two three four five one two three
four five and five you know I I really
can't complain about that I had some
last minute losses that were ugly I had
some last minute wins
thanks to blunders from other people and
really just an incredible incredible
amazing night
let me say thanks to Sam be slain who
subscribed with prime as well as Andy
mint and people still challenging me to
all sorts of stuff I'm not taking any
challenges right now extreme instinct
says anything for fourth place via super
chat Stuart Keating says I pulled off an
unbelievable win unbelievable loss and
an unbelievable stalemate did the whole
lot 9 this is rough got in the top 50
y'all and Lars Martin thew says this was
fun up till 2:00 a.m. to join please do
it more I think this went well this went
very very well appreciate everybody who
joined me
that's it for today join me tomorrow for
you know the show and the Trump press
conference where he will lie to us
constantly and and all of that stuff I
appreciate all the challenges just
coming in constantly but this is it for
chess for me tonight thanks to everybody
who joined me we'll talk to you tomorrow